Ray Stevenson had a varied acting career,
but arguably his highest-profile roles
were linked to Marvel. He made a
strong impression not only on fans,
but also on the people he worked with on
those films. They spoke up to memorialize him.
On May 22, 2023, news of Stevenson's
death at the age of 58 came as a shock
to fans all over the world. His death
reportedly occurred a day earlier,
and as of the making of this video,
the cause has yet to be made public.
Stevenson turned in numerous memorable
performances on screens big and small
throughout his acting career,
entertaining moviegoers and
television viewers alike in a wide range
of genres. But Marvel fans, of course,
best remember his work under the Marvel
banner, within the MCU and outside of it.
Stevenson's first Marvel role came in
2008 as the title character in "Punisher:
War Zone," a gory and grim take on Frank
Castle's story that's all too often overlooked
during discussions of Punisher adaptations.
Sadly, this turned out to be Stevenson's only
live-action turn in the role, but he'd get
another crack at a Marvel character a few
years later. In 2011's "Thor," he took on
the role of Warriors Three member Volstagg,
which he reprised in the 2013 sequel "Thor:
The Dark World" and 2017's "Thor: Ragnarok."
"My friends! This is good!"
As word of Stevenson's death has spread,
folks that have worked in front of and behind
the camera for Marvel productions made touching
statements on social media in his memory.
James Gunn, director of the "Guardians of
the Galaxy" trilogy and holiday special,
and now the co-head of DC Studios, wrote,
"So sorry to hear about the passing, far
too young, of Ray Stevenson. I only knew
him a little from shooting post-credits of
Thor 2 & a couple interactions at events,
but we had some good laughs & he was a joy to work
with. His friends & family are in my heart today."
Rosario Dawson, who played Claire Temple
on the Netflix Marvel series "Daredevil"
and "Luke Cage," also posted a Twitter tribute to
Stevenson, calling him "vivacious & unbelievably
present & vibrant." Dawson and Stevenson worked
extensively on the upcoming Disney+ "Star Wars"
series "Ahsoka," which will arrive on
the streaming service in August 2023.
Stevenson's work as the fallen Jedi Baylan Skoll
on the program is one of his final performances.
Stevenson was remembered well by his
fellow Warriors Three actors. On Instagram,
Tadanobu Asano, who played Hogun, reminisced
about their time working together. Asano described
Stevenson's kindness, helpfulness, and warmth, and
thanked him for all he did for him. Josh Dallas,
who played Fandral in the first "Thor" movie
before Zachary Levi took over the role in "Thor:
The Dark World" and "Thor: Ragnarok," posted
about Stevenson on his Instagram story, writing,
"Rest in peace Ray."
Jaimie Alexander, who has played Lady
Sif in a number of Marvel productions,
shared some photos of herself and
Stevenson on set. She began her caption,
"Ray. Man. My heart is shattered.
You made everyday so much fun on
and off set. You always looked
after me. Always made me laugh."
Alexander recalled Stevenson visiting her
in the hospital and their unforgettable
dinners. Though she had plenty
of stories to share about him,
she wished they had the chance to make
even more memories. She concluded her post,
"I'm sending so much love to
your beautiful family. Love you."
Just as he did with fans of his
work, Ray Stevenson clearly left
a lasting impression on many of his
co-stars. He is already sorely missed.